Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie
This will be my full Marvel
What if Season 2 Episode 9 Finale Video
There are a whole bunch of Easter Eggs and references
We just got the What if Season 3 Trailer too
I've already done a video for it I posted on
my channel, so add a link for that at the end of this.
so it sounds like we might actually be getting
what if season three in like a couple months?
Like why drop a teaser trailer for season 3
if you're not going to drop episodes really soon?
if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
Whenever they do wind up releasing that,
of course I will do episode videos for that too.
but careful for spoilers.
If you haven't seen the episode yet,
we'll start at the beginning.
Work our way through, shot by shot, talking
about the many, the many Easter eggs and references.
Like there were so many things in this episode.
It took me forever to take all the notes
to even record this video.
lots of zooming,
lots of enhancing all over the episode, even the intro.
but Starting with the episode title.
What if Strange Supreme intervened.
It's meant to be a parallel to the season one finale,
which was
what if the Watcher broke his oath and intervened
basically.
They did a fully customized Marvel Studios intro,
and it's the long version
with the full Marvel Studios fanfare.
they've done that for a couple of movies now.
But this is the first time
they've done it for an actual series.
basically replacing all the MCU characters
in scenes with scenes from what
If and characters both season
one and season two so far.
they just did it for Guardians of the Galaxy 3.
They did one for Chadwick Boseman in Black Panther,
Wakanda Forever.
They also did
one for Stan Lee in the first Captain Marvel movie.
So they'll continue to do stuff like that
every once in a while.
there's so many Easter Eggs
and references in this intro.
So just starting at the beginning here,
it starts with Iron Man's Sarkar in Trash Buster Armor.
happy Hogan is the freak a.k.a Purple Hulk.
It also has a quote from him in episode three.
It is taken from the script.
Like the font here is almost like they copy
pasted the lines from the scripts
and they did it for a couple of different characters
across the intro is basically him referencing
getting his powers
T'Challa Star-Lord with a quote from him
in his original episode, Bill Foster Goliath
with a quote from him.
In his episode, Cory read
Guardian is here because he's in that missing episode
that they moved to season three.
I literally just posted a trailer video
for What If Season three
The footage is mostly taken from that Red Guardian
episode.
Originally,
it was supposed to happen during season two.
No idea why they moved it to season three, if you look,
there's even a line of dialog from the script
so definitely it seems like their plans changed
on the fly really late in the game.
it just seems kind of funny.
Like this phantom episode where we saw Red Guardian
and he spoke this dialog like,
yeah, I remember that season two episode.
Everybody is going to be scratching their heads.
They don't understand what it means.
this is supreme strange.
It seems like from season one, Captain Carter
with the line that she said in her very first episode
this is the same scene of Captain America
throwing the shield in the regular Marvel
Studios intro, but it's Captain Carter instead.
They basically give a lot of the same scenes
from that original intro, just replacing them
with what if characters.
To the right is the watchers outline
against the stars that you see
in all the
what if intros when he's narrating the intro.
this is the scene of hela learning space
kung fu in Airbending in her episode
to the right is Supreme Strange
from his original episode in season one On the left is
Iron Man on Sacar winning the race in his custom car
that turned into his version of the Hulkbuster suit.
to the left of him.
His cohort from her original episode.
In front on the right is Winter Soldier Steve Rogers.
From the episode in season two.
in the back is Scarlet Witch, Nick Fury.
Couple of the other characters
in the Marvel 62 episode.
In that scene to her left in the back
is Bruce Banner Hulk also from that same episode
as they zoom out, there's a ton more scenes,
like a ton more references here.
Some of them are season one, summer season two.
Starting on the left,
there's Captain Marvel from her episode in season one.
She's also fighting Thor.
In another scene in one of the other letters,
like inside the letter.
behind them is Raymond during the Killmonger season
one episode where he killed T'Challa
and took over Wakanda To the right is the younger ego
the Living Planet?
From season two Episode one Further right is Iron
Man in the Donut from the Iron Man
two scene in season one to the left is Black Widow
with Red Guardian Shield from season one.
Way back here is the Grandmaster
in the Iron Man, Season two episode.
behind him are The Avengers from the Marvel Zombies
episode in season
one before they turned into zombies,
there's another Captain Marvel scene below them.
And then there's another Captain Marvel scene
from season one over here.
This one is Gamora from the season one finale.
And as they continue to pan out,
the scene changes and starts rotating around
from that scene in the finale from season one.
this Winter Soldier is from season one.
There's Infinity Ultron next to him from season one.
There's a Howard the Duck from season one.
This is Nick Fury from season one on top of him
after he switches this.
Thor is also meant to be from season one.
There are a couple other characters
that I'm probably missing here, so if you spotted any
that I didn't mention in this part of the intro,
just write them below in the comments.
But like you could watch the intro like five or six
times,
zooming in, enhancing over every single pixel
and still find new stuff.
somebody clearly spent like an entire year
making this intro.
the actual episode starts with the watcher
narrating against the sky
in the aftermath of the episode, a marvel 62 episode.
Basically, Peggy Carter is still trapped there,
but she did fix the universe.
It was reset back to normal.
he does a recap of her stories
since season one in her backstory with clips
from all of her episodes, I think to bookend her
storyline at the end of this episode.
Because the way they ended her storyline
at the end of the finale here,
it was kind of like the old man, Captain America,
ending in Avengers Endgame, works.
He takes the long way around like,
take me on a tour of the multiverse before you take me
home, old man Captain America's
final mission to return the Infinity Stones,
but then also taking a little bit of a detour
on the way back for about 80
plus years, living a life with his Peggy Carter
before he came back to the present day.
so it almost seems that they're telling us
that Peggy Carter won't be like the main focus
in Season three,
the way she was during season one and season two,
when the watcher says her loss of her,
Steve Rogers, could have consumed her.
It's meant to foreshadow Supreme Strange
becoming the main villain in the episode
because he became obsessed
with bringing his Christine back
and they really buried the lead on this supreme
strange reveal.
I'm totally fine with him
being the actual main villain for season two.
It makes sense for the character
that that's the arc that he would be on.
Like he seemed like he'd
been kind of corrupted during season one.
But the way they ended his storyline in season one,
it seemed like he'd repented.
so one of my only complaints about the finale, it's
relatively minor complaint is
they should have used like a couple more post-credits
scenes to set up that character turn for him.
So that it wasn't like, hey, by the way, I'm
super evil now and I'm going to kill everybody
trying to bring my universe back.
he's using her as bait to capture Cordy again
because he's collecting all the most
powerful villains and heroes from the multiverse
to fuel his multiverse forge
in a bid to recreate his original universe
and bring his Christine back.
The funny thing about this,
you really want to get into the weeds,
like if you're not a big comic book reader,
this is a power that Franklin Richards has.
Like what Doctor Strange Supreme is trying to do
is something that Franklin Richards just
has is one of his regular old powers,
basically creating entire universes.
In fact, during that more recent secret wars
that I just referenced
at the end of that, Franklin Richards
basically helps them fix the multiverse
by just recreating
all the dead universes one at a time with Mr.
Fantastic Help.
during Doctor Strange Multiverse of Madness,
John KRASINSKI'S Reed Richards
even said that Franklin existed in this universe
like he had multiple children.
Franklin was one of them.
So this is pretty strange.
Was really dead set on bringing his Christine back.
He should have just gone to Franklin Richards.
He calls out her wearing the Union Jack on her uniform.
That's the British flag.
I talked about that in my previous Marvel 1602 episode,
The Guardians of the Multiverse
that he references was the name of their Multiverse
Avengers team in season one.
The Watcher
then does a recap of Supreme Strangers story to sort of
set up the turn in the episode They use the normal
what if intro though no special changes to this.
he takes her to his new sanctum sanctorum that he's
been using since season one, Calling it the Sanctum.
Infinite him like the Infinity Sanctum.
I'm assuming that means it also exists in its own
little pocket
dimension, in
not some random universe on a random earth.
he shows her all the villains he's been collecting
from different universes in the little globes.
When they start panning across them from left to right.
Like this is another big zooming and enhancing
kind of moment.
Took me a while to do all these notes.
they start with the Infinity Ultron from season one.
Here's the weird thing, though.
He's got all the infinity stones in his armor,
even though later in the episode they show Killmonger
from that same episode in season one,
wearing the Infinity Stones in his armor.
that might just be a small animation error
because like, I don't think there are multiple Infinity
Ultron out there
running around is living infinity Gantlets below him.
The Gnome is actually a character from Marvel Comics
just called Gnome.
He's actually a scientist.
He's mostly like a name or villain.
there's a Thanos with the Infinity gantlet next to him.
There's a Loki next to him, a hela next
to Loki on the far left.
I think this is meant to be wenwu in the collector
from season one.
Below them.
some of the characters here in the background
are a little too blurry to make out,
but they basically have all the characters
breaking out later in the episode.
So I'll point some of the other ones
that they don't show you on the shelves here.
this one is Rocket with that giant gun,
Young Peter Quill from episode one.
This one is actually the Hulk
with the powers of Thor wielding a sword
laced with gamma energy,
like he crackles with gamma like electricity.
he's actually based on a very recent Marvel comic book,
just the last couple of years called Banner of War,
when he and Thor basically trade powers
like Thor against the powers of the Hulk.
And Hulk gets the powers of Thor,
The reason why this is the Hulk with Thor's powers,
not the other way around, is because Thor's
hair is still super long when he holds out,
he also doesn't have any special sleeping armor
like this Hulk does.
there's a Corvus glaive.
Next to them, there's another Thor on the far right.
Supreme Strange makes fun of the Watcher
for never intervening in the affairs of people
from the third dimension,
even though he literally did that during season one.
he also confirms the watcher is a fifth dimensional
being sort of explaining how he's able to exist
this way in view all of these different universes
in his little alternate dimension base,
like they're watching a bunch of different television
shows, It also explains how he's so powerful to
she makes a bunch of movie references
Gremlins, Aliens, Jurassic Park.
Been catching up on that list
that we saw during Captain America Winter Soldier.
those are all meant to be movies
where dangerous creatures escaped wreaking havoc.
But other secret reference here foreshadowing Doctor
Strange Supremes evil Turn in all of those movies,
the actual main villain winds up being some evil
person, not the actual creatures themselves.
is meant to be a reference to,
like all the villains here at the end of the episode,
wind up giving them their weapons
to help defeat Strange Supreme,
and he winds up being the actual main villain.
she gets her upgraded modern armor
because she was still wearing her medieval era armor.
He sends her to a universe where Red Skull
was successful in taking over the planet.
this is his face on Mount
Rushmore in the scene is basically meant
to be a reference to Hawkeye
versus Quicksilver in Avengers Age of Ultron.
Bet she did not see that coming.
I'm sure
everybody was watching the scene, pointing up
at the screen, just like going for Leonardo DiCaprio
meme, like, she's doing the thing
before she winds up running into her, though
the watcher shows up explaining the backstory
this universe and warns her about getting involved
when he says that he can't bear to narrate
what happens next is
because he knows everything that's happening
with Supreme Strange like the truth of it all.
But because his oath is to never intervene.
He's allowing it all to proceed Like events
will just unfold however they're supposed to unfold.
I'm not supposed to get involved, cohort.
He explains everything to Captain Carter.
What's really going on with Supreme Strange,
and then he yanks them back to his sanctum sanctorum.
they both wind up revealing the truth of the matter,
and he admits to it eventually.
when they're fighting,
they start panning across all the different villains
as Captain Carter is deciding which ones to release.
This one is a cowboy. Loki.
This one's another happy Hogan freak Purple hulk.
Basically Below him are some characters we saw before.
Like, this is the collector from season one.
There's a wicked vampire
looking Howard the duck next to him.
I'm not sure this crazy tentacle being is.
He looks like he has a gem in his forehead,
but there are a couple of characters like that in.
None of them have tentacles.
we get another great protector dragon.
And when she starts freeing them,
the dragon actually crashes into a bunch of others,
freeing even more people.
they're couple different rooms and there's
a bunch of stuff going on in the background.
But just starting with this first one, they start
with Happy Hogan Freak, Adult Star-Lord, a story.
There's a vision behind them. Corvus Glaive.
Cowboy Loki.
binder. Here are cool Obsidian fighting the collector.
There's another Captain Marvel
in the background here too.
Here's a proxima Midnight.
There's a bunch of randos
that are all blurring the distance here.
Like random troops,
like dark elves, asgardian soldiers.
Soldiers from the ten rings Army.
We go to the next room, we get another.
When Wu with the ten rings, his army fighting,
more shattering the background.
There's a corridor here, a scroll.
There's the Hulk with the powers of the Thor,
the banner of war.
We get that crazy looking rocket, a dark elf.
They run into a zombie Scarlet Witch from season
one with a bunch of zombies.
It's the same group that we saw during season one.
Like just after the events of those episodes.
It sounds like Supreme Strange captured them
Then Helen takes control of them with the power
of the eternal flame in Odin's treasure vault
like she did in Thor Ragnarok with her undead army.
When she says Zombies my kind of party.
That's also a reference to her scene in Thor Ragnarok,
because it's
literally an undead zombie army that she resurrects.
I also think that they're implying in the episode
that this HeLa is actually meant
to be the main 616 version of HeLa from Thor Ragnarok
I think that's why
when Serdar comes in and says his line
also from Thor Ragnarok I am Asgard's Doom.
They both recognize each other
like they clock each other for a second.
Like, wait a minute, it's you.
it's you. And they lunge at each other again.
So I think the idea is that she disappears
at the end of that movie, people are like, Did she die?
Obviously, she probably did not die.
You don't see a body.
They're not dead. Supreme. Strange.
Probably just the point, both of them at that moment
and put them in prisons.
Kahhori references Queen Isabella
from her episode at the end when mocking
hell, telling her to kneel like the last person
that did that didn't end up so great.
they almost fall afoul of Thanos
with the Infinity gantlet,
who's ultimately killed by Killmonger,
using his infinity gantlet, snapping his fingers.
How ironic.
trying to snap them away,
but also snapped away yourself.
And it is meant to be the Killmonger
from the end of season one,
Kahhori uses her powers to teleport him directly
out of the armor.
Real quick fix to that problem.
back in the air, we see two versions of Thor
attacking each other with their hammers,
causing this massive explosion.
And Captain Carter is able to transfer the infinity
stones to her armor, giving her a huge power upgrade
She has a couple of those later
in the episode to their fight scene
with all the different infinity stone powers
one at a time is pretty cool.
Like all the different combinations, the user is
sort of like a little kid with their toy box.
Like, okay, we've got a bunch of different toys here.
Let's just make them do really cool stuff.
some really cool Easter eggs
in the actual way that they animate this too,
when they're blasting each other with cosmic energy.
They also use the Kirby Crackle effect in animation.
It was just Jack Kirby's way of depicting
cosmic energy, like really powerful cosmic energy.
They use it during season one,
when the watcher is using his powers.
you've also probably seen it
many times during the Spider-Man
into the Spider-Verse in Spider-Man,
across the Spider-Verse movies.
The duplication spell here is a reference to Avengers
Infinity War.
In his fight with Thanos, Captain Carter
also uses her reality stone to do the exact same thing
They start playing the doctor. Strange theme music.
They play a little bit of Captain Carter's
theme music, a little bit of Avengers
theme music mixed in here, too.
when he turns all of her copies into butterflies.
That's also the spell
he used during Avengers Infinity War,
and he sends her into a mind space version
of a fake reality, tempting her
with the idea that he can send her to a reality
like a universe where she could be with her.
Steve Again.
when she escapes, he starts portraying
everyone just directly into his forge.
They start falling.
Everyone starts throwing their ultra
powerful weapons and armor to her, to even the odds
just a little bit more.
and it's another one of those moments where, like,
you can picture a little kid with a bunch of different
Marvel toys,
like trying to give one character every single weapon.
Like, how many weapons can we put on this character?
How powerful would that make them?
Who cares that this makes sense?
It just looks really cool.
maybe, maybe Marvel and Disney will start selling.
This is an actual toy like her action figure here
wearing all these weapons and armors.
Notice when Heller throws her her crown, she says,
Give them hell.
They actually spelled it right in the subtitles
in this episode, it's HDL.
That's the Asgardian version of the underworld,
the alternate dimension where Odin banished her
in Thor Ragnarok.
she uses the time stone to stop their falling.
And when Strange says
that he mastered that a long time ago,
that's referenced in his original episode in Season
one where he used his time stone to reverse time
over and over again, trying to find different ways
to save his Christine one of the Thor's
gives her his hammer when Will gives them
their ten rings in the banner of war.
Hulk gives her his sword in spear.
It's Odin Spear from his reality.
Kahhori is able to portal everyone back to their homes,
their original universes,
and uses her space dome powers to wield Thor's hammer.
The reason why she can do that?
Because I know there are a lot of questions about this.
Like, is she worthy?
Is that how she can pick the hammer up?
I think the way they're explaining the logic here
is that she's using
telekinesis
like her space stone powers to wield the hammer.
She's not actually physically touching it in.
That's how she can pick it up.
she can wear the ten rings because those don't have
a worthiness enchantment on them.
Like literally anybody off
the street could wear the ten rings and use them,
when Supreme Strange starts to transform into a demon.
This is meant to be a reference
to the Lord of the Rings
movies in The Hobbit, movies
like The Gandalf versus the Balrog by in in The Hobbit
movies, Benedict Cumberbatch
was actually the voice of Smaug, the Dragon.
he kind of loses control during this fight, too.
So his demonic side
kind of starts to take over his body.
one of the only details
here, though, is that Captain Carter is able to grab
all the infinity stones in her bare fist
in, punched him with them.
Normally that would take her arm off
like that would almost kill her to do that.
Captain America, for instance, during Avengers
Endgame, could have been the one to wield
the Infinity Gantlet,
But even with all of his super soldier powers like he's
enhanced physiology, it almost would have killed him
and it almost would have destroyed his entire body
like it would definitely taken his arm but again,
I think this is one of those moments in the episode
where they're like, who cares if it makes sense?
It just looks cool.
he winds up sacrificing himself to the forge,
giving it enough cosmic energy to power it,
bringing his universe back in his Christine back,
but at the expense of his existence.
Like it literally wipes him from that entire timeline.
So he'll never be born at any point
during that timeline the watcher joins Captain Carter
before she dies, bring her to his base
In sending Cordy back to her universe,
he takes her to Central Park in strange Supremes
Recreated Now a resurrected universe.
We see his version of Christine alive.
But as he explains, Supreme
Strange basically wiped himself from all existence.
So it was like he never existed in this reality.
when the watcher agrees
to take her back to the present day of her universe,
she asks him to take her on a tour of the multiverse
first and reveals Loki's multiverse
treat her from the end of Loki Season two,
confirming where this sort of fits in the timeline
you had imagined Loki sitting in the middle there,
just like holding it all together.
and the reason why they can perceive it
this way is because the Watcher has brought her
to a higher dimension so they can perceive
the multiverse as if it were an actual tree
this kind of the way that Loki
is also sitting there on the rock.
At the end of time
it's meant to be in a higher dimension.
So he perceives timelines as different ropes.
So now the big question is, does that mean
Captain Carter will not come back in season three?
Like, did they wrap up her story with this scene here?
Like you done
a good job, will take you home. That's it.
No more for me.
it does seem like
what if season three will be the actual final season?
And it does seem like it's actually coming pretty soon.
I just did a much bigger trailer video for that and
explained all the episodes that we know about so far.
Like this supposed to be a Moon Knight
episode, a Spider-Man episode.
Even though we do see Spider-Man in season two,
he will be back in season three.
Generally, season two felt like it was pretty solid,
like Marvel 1602 Probably my favorite episode.
They really should have focused more episodes
in that 1602 universe.
They could have done an entire season
in the 1602 universe If you spotted any other Easter
eggs or references in the episode that I didn't mention
in the video, just write them below in the comments
and also just post all your favorite moments
from the season.
really big reminder, too,
is that the next big series is going to be Echo
I'll be doing a couple of episode videos for that
and really meta Easter egg To the person
who played Kahhori
Devery Jacobs is actually playing a different character
during Echo, but I don't think she's meant
to be connected to her Kahhori character.
Like it's not a multiverse situation
or anything like that
click here for that brand new What if Season 3
Trailer and click here for all my What If episodes
Thank you so much for watching
Happy holidays everyone,
and I'll see you guys in the next one!